[موسيقى]
نظره قريبه من التحالف الاوروبي الامريكي
الداعم لاوكرانيا قد تشي ان بعض التصدعات
تشوب تماسكه فاجتماع الدول الداعمه في
قاعده رمشتاين الجويه في المانيا كشف عن
مخاوف بعض الدول الاوروبيه من نوعيه
الاسلحه التي ترسل الى اوكرانيا الدبابات
تحديدا
الطريق الى رمشتاين سبقها سجله بين
المانيا وحلفائها في النيتو حول ارسال
دبابات الاكياف بدايه نقل عن المستشار
الالماني قوله لنرسل او نسمعها بارسال
دبابات الى اوكرانيا قبل ان ترسل الولايات
المتحده دباباتها ليعود المتحدث باسم
الحكومه الالمانيه ويقول ان برلين لم تربط
ابدا ارسل دبابات الى برد القتاليه
الالمانيه الى اوكرانيا بارسال الولايات
المتحده دبابات ابرامز
ذلك نفي وزير الدفاع الالماني
بورسبيستوريوس عرقله التسليح قائلا ان اي
قرار في هذا الشان لم يتخذ بعد ويجب تقييم
ايجابيات وسلبيات هذه الخطوه بعنايه شديده
اما الولايات المتحده فتستمر بتقديم
تفسيرها في عدم ارسال دبابات ام واحد الى
اوكرانيا
ليس لدينا اي اعلان جديد
الدفاع الالماني ان بلاده لم تتخذ قرارا
بعد بخصوص دبابات للبرد
على الرغم من الضغوط التي تمارس على
المانيا لارسال الدبابات تتشارك برلين
وباقي دول اوروبا في الخشيه من احتمال
استعمال كياس اسلحتها الثقيله في ضرب عمق
الاراضي الروسيه ما يعني توريطها بحرب
هجوميه وليست دفاعيه خاصه تلك التي تملك
حدود مباشره او قريبه مع روسيا ومن هنا
يمكن فهم حظر المانيا التي لا تزال مطارده
باخطاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وبينما يستمر السجال للتحذيرا مفاده ان
تسليم اسلحه بعيده المدى لاوكرانيا يعني
انني ساعه سيبلغوا مستوى جديده في الاثناء
تصرك ياف على حاجتها للدبابات ان ارادت
تعزيز قدراتها الميدانيه لا سيما في مناطق
الاشتباك القريبه